I skip how are how are you what did you
make your rookie year my work he here
32000 did you - no did you do anything
with it did you splurge on anything you
know what's so funny is I was drafted in
the first round and I got a hundred
thousand dollar bonus and my math skills
were so in-depth I thought I'd never
have to work again I thought I was
wealthy beyond belief
you know just okay that kind of goes to
show you my educational background do
you wish you had gone to college why did
i cure I just I went three years but
unfortunately still a freshman well then
do you wish you'd gone right out of high
school no I'm glad I didn't I was
drafted by the second I was drafted in
the second round by the cups high in the
second round and they offered me $18,000
and when I when I left to go to
University of Arizona you know I made
one last call to him because I did want
to play baseball and they tried to find
me out of my scholarship and they
offered me 19,000 and in the end I'm
kind of glad that I did because I
haven't got it been one of those guys
that fell through the cracks I want some
very strong kind of immature
and I think the three years of college
was wonderfully when did you realize
that you could be a manager probably not
until the day somebody called asked me
you know I think because I got hurt so
early in my career I started to just try
to make myself valuable enough to be on
a team you know whether it was a
pinch-hitter a defensive replacement
something whatever a team needed and I
didn't realize that at the time but it
was starting to prepare me for maybe
being a manager you know when you still
have mentioned you you wonder when
you're gonna pinch-hit so you always try
to be ready so you're really thinking
kind of like a manager even though that
wasn't my thought at the time but when
buddy Bell called masked me if I wanted
to be a minor league coach and then
manager that's what I saw
I realized just how passionate I was
about it I mean I loved it I got those
greatest thing ever do you have a caste
system with your players like certain
players get more attention or they get
more freedom is everybody treated the
same I guess is the question we try
really hard to cuz I don't like that
caste system and for a couple reasons
one if you yell at the young guys about
not hustling and you don't about the
veterans well I think your message
becomes kind of diluted or doesn't mean
very much so we try to hold the veterans
to the highest standard so when we say
something to everybody it means the same
and I'll give you another example like
you know in spring training in Arizona
where you know you can drive to the
games we a if you're on our team you're
allowed to drive you don't have to be
good you don't have to be the best you
don't have to be a mainstay you know we
we try to go out of our way to treat
everybody the same but did you treat
Jordan the same when you had him in in
the summer league in Arizona oh we try I
mean obviously you got to be a little
bit the telogen about the old some
things I mean like we we had a thing
where all the guys used to go work out
lift stuff on the road and to take him
would have been a fiasco because nobody
would have got anything done so you know
we've been some rules but but we also
again and I Eve heard me say this before
Michael was so good about being part of
what we were doing that it never gotten
away so it was funny one time I was
yelling at the guys I didn't think they
were doing very well during infield
practice I was kind of getting on them
and after I'm done he walked over he
goes I know you're talking how much
pressure is on the Indians added
pressure that LeBron is left town and
Cavs not what they once were no you know
what not none I mean shoot iron I was a
bigger bran fan as everybody I mean
shoot you know him leaving you know I'm
already more worried
like the downtown and kind of the
economy or what he did for the downtown
but I mean it's hard enough to win
baseball games we can't try to win more
because LeBron last shoot that that
doesn't help anybody we're talking to
Terry Francona the Indians manager when
yesterday over the Pirates and today
they got the Tigers coming up later on
tonight take us back to July 10th and
the call to the bullpen oh you mean the
mix-up yeah I was gonna say you gotta be
because I can barely remember now at all
is there any humor attack what kind of
has to be I mean I've had friends come
up to me like one guy came up to me a
half hour after he goes is it too soon
you know we were in the middle of a kind
of a meltdown inning you know Cody was
having a heck of an inning and my head
was spinning I'm trying to figure out if
we're gonna walk I think it was Scott
schebler or you know we're gonna pitch
to the next guy and I think Carl Willis
his head was spinning because the way
Cody was pitching and I walked over to
him and I said you know get you know P
up I was just trying to be in case we
got around to Fox and I think in the
midst of everything he thought I said ot
and I'll be damned here I go out to the
mound it's four to three weeks
bases-loaded and I see Dan and taro
coming through and what really what the
worst thing the worst thing of all for
me was not what people said about me I
felt bad for in Attero because I put him
in a terrible position because all of a
sudden here he comes
you know through the gates and he's not
the guy we wanted and that's not a knock
on him that was just you know it was it
was the right situation for Oliver Perez
and that's my mistake and and I tried
own up to it I mean you know I think as
a manager when you make a mistake you
got to own up to it now saying that you
better not make very many of those
doesn't work okay now what is the
solution so what's the new policy when
you call to the bullpen and it's ot or
Opie
now it's not that somebody asked me that
it's not a it's just I just need to
probably speak more clearly and and it
was one of those perfect storm things
where we were in the middle of a
meltdown was probably spitting tobacco
all for everybody else in myself and
just need to slow down and make sure
that we're on the same page that's all
when did you start chewing tobacco um
when I was a young player and I wasn't
playing you know you kind of get bored
and you start to mess around I couldn't
do when I played and you know obviously
I get so nervous during games I still do
that I kind of choose the inside of my
cheek because I guess getting nervous
now I'm wrapping gum because one it's a
terrible habit and I and I know it and I
don't want kids seeing it thinking it's
cool so always try to wrap it gum just
because I just don't yeah I don't know I
just don't think it's a great message to
sense but I don't try to lie about it
either I mean it's it's there and I do
it the day the season's over I quit and
then the day the season starts I start
again man I don't know who came up with
this so I tried it and I got so buzzed
and then one time I swallowed some and I
went I'll never be a big leaguer cuz I
can't shoot tobacco look you know it's
funny Dana you this is you know I do the
dista back oh the leaf tobacco the the
Copenhagen stuff this stuff yeah I tried
that my first week at college I was in a
rush party and I ended up sleeping
underneath the wheel of a fire engine
because it didn't agree with me at all I
can't even smell it to this day but but
now with the leaf stuff if I swallow it
I've been doing as long as all it does
is give me the hiccups so it's it's
amazing how different it is I had
somebody on I'm trying to think who the
analyst was but they said I it might
have been Kevin Millar or Sean Casey and
I said you know best two guys on a team
in baseball right now I said you know
would you take Giancarlo Stanton and
Aaron Judge
he said no I take Lindor and Ramirez
it's pretty high praise there I think
that I think that's very astute also and
I think there are very worthy of
conversations like that I mean they're
both 25 years old or at least under you
know whatever 24 and 25 they're better
days maybe ahead of them and I mean they
they're they're unbelievable they may
not be as big as judge in Gordon but
they are there are tremendous players
and they love playing the game they're
good for the game so great for the
Indians but they're also good for the
game yeah and Lindor loves to play I
mean just his enthusiasm is contagious
I'd put Ramirez in that group too I mean
this kid is everywhere on every place if
you ever look up and see a pop up to the
catcher Ramirez is standing right next
to him
I mean I'd put I'd love for beer is in
that same concentration who does Mike
Trout remind you of I tell Mike spar bar
third-base coach he reminds me of all
time so far he's about 511 excuse him
all the time it looks like he has weak
eyes like a disease because he doesn't
have any muscles I don't know being
proud reminds me more of like a running
back you know with those shoulders that
you know I mean it's just so broad in
the shoulders why why who you get that
no I'm just curious you remind you of me
no no no but I'm you know because
there's this old-school feel of him and
I don't know as long as you've been
around baseball where you go you know
what I I kind of see trades here of you
know because he's mentioned with the
Great's of all time Terry you know
that's why maybe Ted Kluszewski you know
the guy that he's ahead of me was my dad
but that's the guy with the arms where
they had to kind of make beautiful
difference because he's here right I
mean he's he's got such raw you know
he'll take swings and you're not even
sure is a great swing but he just and
then you look up if you are lands I mean
he just and he plays so hard a plays
every day I mean he's
these good fries another guy who's good
for the game you're not really thrilled
with her playing guest but he's good all
right if I said you could buy stock in
another player on another Tim and I gave
you Bryce Harper Mike Trout Erin judge
and Shohei Otani oh man I don't know I
mean I I gotta be careful when you start
talking about other players there's so
many good ones I I think right now one
of the better players in the game might
be the kid that just went to the Dodgers
Machado
you know me yeah I mean he it's the guy
that can play third and short and he did
every time he swings I I know we sit in
the dial my god he swings hard he throws
his back out because it's just I've
never takes so many good swings that it
just scares you like you take a swing
you know fact like Oh God
you know he's so close and just every
iPad it's just it just gut-wrenching is
there a guy where you know when the ball
leaves his bat like it's a home run
I guess they're not on your team but is
there a guy like have you ever been
looking down all of a sudden you just
hear it you know that it's gone when you
see the guys in New York now like judge
and those those guys what judge hit a
ball at our place
and I was glad he used the 200 instead
of maybe a four because it didn't get up
enough to go out but it was just you
know it was like think the exit velocity
was like 111 you know it's just a rocket
but unfortunately use the wrong Club for
him I couldn't imagine playing third
base it's like when Willie McCovey and
Willie Stargell played like you I just
couldn't imagine me in there at third
base the one game against them they were
starting to pull away so we played the
infield in and I know Ramirez and Linda
looked at me like you come out here
playing and rightfully so hey good to
talk to you and thanks for joining us as
always being my joy to take your medal
to you all right Mitch Terry Francona
Indians manager Continental Tire Coach's
Corner always good to catch up with him
he's one of my favorites Continental
Tire is proud to be the exclusive tired
Patrick show no matter where you drive
or what you drive continental designs
tires for what you do for more
information
Continental Tire comm Continental Tire
for what you do for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]